When I was 18 years old, everything I knew
about paying for college could have fit on
the postage stamp that came on my acceptance
letter.
Going to college can be a gold-mine -- the
average college graduate makes about a million
dollars more over their lifetime than someone
without a degree!
But the overall profitability of your degree
depends greatly on how you pay for it.
The path to hitting the mother-lode can be
strewn with twists, turns and dead ends.
But if you’re willing to put in the work,
there’s actually a lot of gold in them thar hills!
70% of college students don’t have their
education costs fully covered by family.
So prospecting for financial aid is a new
student’s most important first step.
But where to begin?
With the ultimate financial aid treasure-map
-- the Free Application For Student Aid, or FAFSA.
It’s a 108 questions that digs into
your personal and financial history.
It’s your best shot for obtaining the most
amount of free or low-cost college aid out there.
Surprisingly, only 61% of high school students
are filling it out.
Yes, it might look intimidating at first.
But most people report that completing the
entire form only takes about an hour, it can
be sent to 10 schools at once, and you can
do it before you even apply to college!
There’s even a handy website that lists
common mistakes to avoid when completing the FAFSA
And hey...now that you’re a legal adult,
you may as well get used to filling out tedious forms.
Each school will send you an award-letter
with different offers.
You’ll need to sift through the sediment
to find what treasure may lie beneath the surface.
The real paydirt you’re hoping for
is “free money”, AKA grants and scholarships.
These might come from the federal government,
the state or the school itself.
The amount you’re offered can be need based
or merit based, so having a low family income
or high grades will help your chances.
But contrary to popular belief, there is no
“income cut-off” when it comes to aid
so don’t let that stop you from prospecting.
Over 13 million students receive financial
aid every year, so how can you get a leg up
in this gold rush?
First, FILE EARLY.
Gift aid is first-come first-served.
If you wait too long to stake a claim, you
could find the vein has been bled dry..
FAFSA forms become available the first of
October, and you’ll have to redo it every
year, so put an ongoing reminder in your calendar!
If you’re still a dependent, most of the
FAFSA information
will be based on your parents’ finances.
If you happen to go back and forth between
guardians’ households, spending more time
with the lower-earning parent could make you
eligible for more needs-based aid.
Or if one parent has children already in college,
claiming them as the custodial parent could
also end up putting more in your pocket.
And finally, you can appeal the letter if
you don’t love the outcome!
Try calling their financial aid department
and explaining your situation.
You can even show them award letters for colleges
that are offering you more.
You might have more leverage than you think.
Your award letter will let you know whether
you’re eligible to take part in a work-study
program!
In 2019 only 14% of students took advantage
of jobs offered through their university.
You’ll probably only make a few thousand
dollars during the academic year, but the
perks can be sweet.
Working on-campus, you won’t have to commute.
Your hours are always scheduled around your
classes and some even allow you to do homework
on the job!
Most importantly, you could get a headstart
on your career by getting work experience
in your chosen field while you’re still
in school.
Now, I know the idea of cobbling together
a free ride is super appealing.
But it might be time for a little reality
check.
According to a study done back in 2016, only
18.8 percent of undergraduate students received
enough gift aid to cover half the cost of
attendance.
So unless you can make up the difference with
savings or working a ton, you might have to
prepare yourself to join the 70% of your fellow
graduates in taking on some student loans.
And it’s important to learn that not all
of them are created equal.
Federal student loans typically have the most
favorable terms, depending on your FAFSA,
can even be subsidized, which means the government
actually pays the interest while you’re
in school, and sometimes even afterwards.
Even unsubsidized federal student loans have
advantages.
You don’t have to pay while you’re still
in school.
And once you’re out, some will allow you
to adjust your payment schedule based on your
income, so it never gets too onerous.
If you end up working in certain fields, like
teaching or healthcare in underserved areas,
your federal loans could be eligible for forgiveness.
The last type of aid is private student loans.
They can seem attractive at first because
you don’t have to bother with the FAFSA.
But you will have to show credit-worthiness
and ability to pay back the loan.
Since this is tough for young folks, you might
have to get a family member to co-sign for
these.The terms and conditions of these are
set by the lender, rather than the government.
And interest rates are typically higher..
Federal loans are currently offered around
4.5% interest, while the average private fixed-rate
loan starts around 6.17%.
That might not sound like a huge spread, but
with the average student debt load hovering
around 31 grand and taking 21 years to pay
off, those couple percentage points could
mean $7,000 in interest alone!
Some private student loans can go as high
as 14%!
I’m too afraid to do the math on that one…but
this is starting to feel
more like fool's gold to me.
As you can see there are a lot of different
paths to tread when it comes to paying for college
And I think it’s a pretty good parallel
to life in general.
Truly valuable things are usually hidden behind
a lot of hard work and sacrifice whereas easier
paths come with a ton of strings attached.
But remember, even if you end up having to
take out loans, it’s not the end of the world.
Any degree, even a 100% financed one, is better
than none at all.
And that’s our two cents!
Having a rough year?
You’re not alone—we’re all trying to
make sense of 2020.
That’s why we think you should check out
Self-Evident, a new show hosted by our friends
Danielle Bainbridge from Origin of Everything
and Ali Mattu from The Psych Show, because
who better than a historian and therapist
to help guide us through this very weird year.
Link in our description!
Hey!
Before you go, PBS Digital Studios and Two Cents want to hear from YOU.
We do a survey every year that helps us make
more of the stuff you want to see, you even
get to vote on potential new shows.
Take the survey at the link in the description
and let them know Two Cents is your favorite!